we're the cast of growing pains and
we're talking to e.t
hi sievers hello
[Music]
it's an et exclusive the classic sitcom
growing pains debuted 35 years ago today
and only we have the siever family back
together again
as long as we got each other the gang's
all here
how does that number sit with you 35
years
it's unbelievable unimaginable and yet
it feels like yesterday in so many
ways yeah we're just missing alan they
always had us laughing had me laughing
they didn't have enough rooms here in
maui so joanna
we ended up sooner or later it had to be
happening
on all he was the most one of the most
charming men
i'd ever met i think i was a little old
for him but
we became really good friends i saw him
a week before he
passed allen passed away suddenly from a
heart attack in 2016
and the absence of the siver family
patriarch was felt by all
it's been years now and i still reach
for the phone occasionally just thinking
hey i've talked to alan a while i want
to say hi
he was a huge part of our lives e.t
visited the growing pain set
22 times during its seven years on the
air it was clear
this cast was just as much family off
screen as they were on
we may never top this in our lives
that's how
special and privileged we feel i always
felt like i was
coming to my second family when we were
on the set we do want to take you guys
back because we found
a little clip of alan talking about you
all
if you can take a look i'm having a
great time doing growing pains we have a
warm uh cast of genuinely nice people
and happy set and jelly filled donuts
every morning when you come to work
he used to cut the tops off all the the
donuts in the morning
we'd come in and there'd be a whole tray
of topless donuts
i miss him so much and there is a real
hole not having him
with us kirk i mean your scenes with
alan were some of the best in television
history i mean just
iconic i think i really really care
about this girl
you know as a young man there was all
these pretty girls that would be on the
set and he would sort of give me
pointers
on you know how to talk to her did he
give you a pointer on how to talk to
chelsea
yeah well i knew that i had to talk to
chelsea before he talked to chelsea
and i'm really glad that i did chelsea
is kirk's wife of 29 years who he met
on the set of growing pains you like me
yeah this was an episode where mike was
uh in a play at school and his co-star
in the play
was played by chelsea noble kiss me
goodbye jessica
but it worked out really well for me
personally and here we are 29 years
later with six kids
you have seen the when we first met
leonardo dicaprio and it's on the
growing pains
i'm moving with deceivers and i'm like
part of the family
what was it like having leo on the set i
just thought he was so sweet and so cute
and he was just so happy to be on set
with us
well what's not to like horseback riding
season mets tickets
we all got along we all loved him i
needed to pass the tiger beat crown
to leonardo because it was his time
excuse me and he wore it well
yeah leo is fine and a heartthrob now
but back in the day baby
you were that centerfold in everybody's
magazine
my kids tell me all that they're like
dad this is so embarrassing these
these these posters of you and
suspenders and tank tops
you should have thought of us back then
hey what about favorite episodes do you
guys have favorite episodes
this is my co-host kurt is my co-host
wait a second go forward no no we we've
just
we've just hijacked entertainment
tonight could you tell me where the
biology lab is
uh tracy your first on-screen kiss would
be brad pitt wasn't it
yes that's actually my job hold up stop
the presses this is an entertainment
tonight exclusively
we should watch the movie is he a good
kisser
oh my god like my mother was there and i
couldn't even tell you
when i was 17 we teased her a lot they
teased me a lot so
jeremy how about you what was your
favorite episode uh for me my favorite
episode was probably the episode we
filmed in hawaii
didn't i tell you guys we'd be in
paradise
et was actually on that maui set back in
1987.
i just want to hang out on the beach and
go boogie boarding
the bottle with my daughter i think my
sister
oh okay oh no you can't let that one
pass you gotta talk sir
the only good girl in the group there
was candace now kurt
your sister candice just completed a
successful
run of fuller house on netflix do you
ever think like maybe we could
reboot growing pains what would we call
it i think allen had
an idea once it was groaning pain
we've actually talked about this so i
don't know guys i think if we're gonna
do this we need to do this soon
all right agree we gotta get on board
hey i know how we could i i
do it if i get to play jason seaver
mike don't be a wise guy mike
i told you eight o'clock sharp mike
do you think leo is gonna come back you
guys don't have to do this for me
we could have leo come back and with an
episode of him
uh like going you know camping out in
the snow
and uh he meets up with a bear i don't
know where it goes from there but
we can make a sitcom episode out of this